you must have moments where you've taken
this uh crazy Journey too seriously
exactly
no but I mean I went to a you and I went
to a Dodgers game together and we're
sitting in Dodger Stadium next to
Kendrick Lamar by the way yeah
and then they start and Bob Newhart was
there it was one of those nights with
Conan Kendrick and and Newhart and
you're just asking yourself
no no it was the craziest group and so
anyway we're there are all four of you
literally together
I went with Jack we went and um it was
such a cool night for me because we
drove over and on the way over you were
like oh I'll play some new music I've
been working on in the car and first of
all rock and roll always beats comedy
comedians don't get to do that I can't
say like I did an interview
hold on a second with David Spade and I
want to play you a couple of tracks from
it you know what's what's really boost
the bass on David Spade's voice you know
it doesn't work that way so so but you
get to play this amazing music and I'm
like [ __ ]
better to be a rock star I don't know so
anyway we get to
Dodger Stadium we hook up with our Posse
Kendrick Lamar Bob Newhart and um oh my
God I remember sitting with you in
Dodger Stadium and they start to go
and you're just sitting there and I'm
like this has become an Anthem that is
ubiquitous in across the globe and and
and
everyone knows how it goes you and it's
one of the most famous you know licks
riffs Tunes ever and I was just sitting
with you going like all right this is
you you know I think I started to make
up lyrics about monies coming in your
body
but it reminded me like how [ __ ]
freaky that must be it's pretty strange
yeah I there's a my mother was a huge
fan of the movie Yankee Doodle Dandy
yeah me too I still love it to this day
and um uh so he's obviously playing the
character George M Cohen and who had
written the Big World War one song over
there and at the last scene in the movie
I think he he walks out of the White
House and there's a there's a parade of
soldiers singing over there and he's
walking with them yeah
and uh yeah we we've got a soldier next
to him uh James Cagney says what's the
matter Old Timer you don't know this
song yeah and um
yeah he wrote it and uh I think of that
every time I hear that uh Seven Nation
Army on uh Sports so uh broadcast or
something on TV it has the same feeling
that it's not mine anymore I mean uh you
you it becomes folk music when things
like that happen becomes something that
um the hap the more people don't know
where it came from the happier I am you
know the more it just becomes yeah
ubiquitous and I'm sure many people are
chanting the melody have no idea what
the song is or where it came from or why
or whatever it doesn't matter anymore
and that's just amazing right and you
and it's funny because over time you
will even lose your connection to where
you were sitting when you came up with
that oh you know what I mean yeah or you
guys probably banged that out and said
so quickly we filmed yeah no yeah we'll
get a donut now and that's that's the
level of intensity you know we filmed
that uh recording of that record a bunch
and that I that I know that song was
just filmed for a minute because it was
not considered anything interesting at
that moment it was just other things we
were working on we thought we were
interesting and um so yeah you'll see
that we saw the video today I was like
we should just filmed a little bit more
of this song being recorded that we did
uh yeah but uh yeah No One Ever Knows
that the labels didn't want to release
it as a single when we were coming out
with the album they had picked a
different song so he just goes to show
you even when you've got it right in
front of your face sometimes you still
don't know because it's not about you
know really you can Market something you
can brand something or you can push it
uh or you can try to support it and
build into something bigger but you
really have no idea what's going to
connect with other people